هل شاهدت شخصا يوما ما يرمي القمامه من
نافذه سيارته واردت ان تعيد رميه بها شاهد
هذه المراه ترمي علبه سجائر فارغه من
نافذه سيارتها لتقترب امراه اخرى بدراجات
الناريه وترميها بمنفذ سجائر الشارع ثم
تهرب حصل الفيديو على تعليقات مثل هذه هي
بطله احلامنا على الدراجه الناريه يبدا
الفيديو بهذه الجمله اريد ان اعيش في
مدينه نظيفه وهنا يرمي هذا الرجل زجاجه من
نافذه سيارته لتاخذ وتلصقها على مراه
السياره وتعليق اخر على هذا الفيديو يقول
هل هناك ميداليه ما نعطيها اياها ثالث
انتقام لها كان عندما قام شخص بسياره
مرسيدس برمي كيس ماكدونالدز من نافذه
سيارته فقامت باللحاق به والنقر على
النافذه الى ان
فتح
وقالت لم تنهي اكلك ثم رمت الكيس
عليه والكثير من الناس يقولون ان الفيديو
معد ومجرد حمله لدعم النظافه ولكن لا نعلم
مدى صدق هذا الفيديو وينتهي الفيديو بكل
من لا يهتم سيعاقب اذا كان رمي القمامه في
الاماكن غير المخصصه لها يزعجك فهذا
الفيديو بالتاكيد
سيسعدك